risen three Titan Lords is not the most
well executed role-playing game you'll
ever play each game system has some kind
of glitch some kind of annoying flaw
something that keeps it from being the
best it can be
what risen three has that will keep you
pressing forward is a sense of grand
adventure as an unnamed adventurer you
travel from one island to another
seeking to unite your body with your
missing soul during your travels you
parley with ghosts train a monkey and
choose which of several powerful
factions to align yourself with these
are the same islands you explored and
risen to but they've been refreshed and
redesigned making risen three more than
just risen to point five on your journey
you meet a number of friends who may
accompany you one at a time including
returning sword wielding bombshell patty
my favorite companion however was bones
a druid with a funny voice and a weird
love of carnage I'm going to big
personalities aside most of your
companions are functionally the same and
it's too bad that you don't see more
variety in their attacks luckily you
gain access to a variety of different
powers of your own it's easy to stick to
the skills that enhance swordplay given
how vital close quarters combat is
during the early game in time however
you'll be summoning hellhounds to your
side and flinging ice shards at golems
if you so choose it's a nice upgrade to
risen twos more passive take on magic
deciding which customization paths to
travel isn't as simple as selecting
possibilities from a skill tree as with
previous risen games you must first
spend glory in order to meet a proper
threshold and then purchase those skills
from a trainer it's a solid leveling
system that forces you into meaningful
choices in the service of your chosen
play style by the end of the game I had
put aside fencing weapons
the supernatural orb the spewed forth
waves of magic sadly those decisions are
diminished somewhat by the combat itself
the fighting is more fluid than it was
in previous risen games but it's too
easy to exploit you can span your dodge
move to avoid damage even if you're
simply doing somersaults against a wall
between that and various AI exploits I
won most battles easily and the great
supply of available provisions ensured I
was always healthy it's unfortunate that
risen three Springs so many irritations
on you the ship battles you get to take
part in later in the game are really
cool at first but why is there no
cooldown bar for your side cannon why do
they let the Beast attack you in ways
you can avoid or defend against why does
the camera contort like that during
execution moves why are some of the
dialogue choices in an order that can
make conversation sound stupid
Balam a always in shitty mood what's up
with the pointless morality system in
which you sometimes lose soul points for
just being kind of indifferent but you
can be a raging [ __ ] a lot of the
time and never lose points
I'm guessing however that if you're
interested in risen 3 you already have a
certain expectation of it you already
know the developer's history are making
interesting exhaustive awkward
role-playing games risen 3 Titan Lords
is not the studio's grandest game but
risen 3 has the potential to sweep you
away as long as you don't mind how often
it rocks the boat
you